most of the time we don't have the
luxury of showing various points of view
so we have to find the right point of
view when we are submitting to journals
or presentations so here's an image that
I made of a microreactor that studies a
particular reaction it was important to
show how this micro reactor was
connected to the analytic pieces and so
here's another point of view showing the
pieces connected to the background so I
worked a little more on this was there a
way to show the microreactor with the
background pieces at an angle this was
okay I wanted to see a little more of
the front of it and so I went to tried
for this one notice something isn't
quite right I hope you are getting more
and more particular with your own images
you see something up here in the corner
that's the shadow we don't want that so
by moving the camera just a little more
to a different angle we get a cleaner
image I wanted to play around a little
bit with the microreactor this
particular one on its own and then what
i did was i duplicated it put a digital
background on it I thought it would be
kind of interesting maybe it could be
used for an introduction slide bottom
line as the researchers never used it so
went back to the clear documentary image
which hopefully really shows what is
going on here and indeed we did get it
published as a cover and also of course
in the figure this is the best point of
view for this particular device